oh
vraiment casimir ta maison est une des
plus belles et des plus authentiques
maison de style casimir eu ce que j'ai
vu un vraiment et qui en a vu beaucoup à
temps j'en ai vu j'en ai vu deux wii 2
seulement oui bon je suis déçu ah bon
mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi quand
on est deux il vaut mieux être dans les
deux premiers que dans les deux derniers
casimir dans les deux premiers dans
l'est de la ligne à oui c'est vrai j'ai
compris we hope romandie tu aurais pu me
dire que ma maison était dans les deux
plus laide que jamais vu
la wii d'autant plus que
mathématiquement c'est parfaitement
exact
oui mais non est ce que ma maison est
très joli mais je ne t'ai pas dit le
contraire casimir je ne cherchait qu'à
te rendre service et à te faire plaisir
moi je sais mais enfin tu as une telle
façon de dire les choses que parfois on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de se mettre en
colère je sais bien je sais bien casimir
notre tante adélaïde me le répète sans
arrêt alors
alors que veux tu faire maintenant nous
pouvons aller faire un tour dans la
montagne en or une promenade au port
d'une baignade à la plage au nord - tu
sais j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien
retourner au jardin aujourd'hui pour
pourparlers avec jury pour la connaître
un peu mieux tu as raison juliette une
fille un formidable
oh oui elle a toutes les qualités non
elle a aussi quelques défauts as tu
crois 1 quel est son plus grand défaut
aux hommes tu verras c'est facile à
deviner elle est désordonné
au bas mot qui croyaient qu'elle avait
toutes les qualités pour moi enfin les
personnes a toutes les qualités a bien
seul au monde
tu en es sûr de ça mais certains voyons
pas même moi alors
écoute si tu veux nous allons jardin et
je suis même sûr tel nous chantera sa
chanson oui oui allons-y attends attends
[Musique]
tu sais bien que j'ai des petits fragile
fait attention mais toi
tu maladroit un salut françois au jury
pelé bonjour bonjour françois ne vous
dérangez pas ça me fait plaisir de vous
accueillir dans notre jardin ah ben oui
je sais très bien mais ne vous dérangez
pas je moi je suis simplement venu voir
julie
moi je ne vous intéresse pas bon mais
côté faut que je parte peut-être non
c'est ça c'est ça au revoir françois
rouan pouvoir
politique aurait dû faire attention il
est parti vexé au mais je ne voulais pas
le vexer casimir moi tu comprends je
sais qu'il travaille beaucoup pour ses
études kaki qu'il travaille énormément
je ne voulais pas le déranger je sais tu
est plein de bonnes intentions mais tu
es tellement maladroit et gaffeur on
écoute je ferai attention bon écoute tu
veux toujours comme giuly nous chante sa
chanson oh oui oh oui tu crois qu'elle
voudra bien or il n'y a pas de problème
tu sais dans l'île aux enfants c'est
très facile à il suffit de prononcer le
mot magique
et lequel
musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
je voudrais faire un thème de meautry
j'y vois les filles et les garçons
[Musique]
casimir show de sa chanson
françois
nouveau jeu
à
[Musique]
mais je n'aurai mieux pas si j'avais
fond
mais j'aimerais mieux peu si j'étais à
l'enfant
[Musique]
oh
dans le kiosque que les poupées
on les remplit les poli
[Musique]
couleur série surtout
à papillons passera
ainsi sur un contre
[Musique]
utile
mais je m'en fais mieux taire si je
faisais la fin
mais je leur ai
si j'étais un grand
gardien
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un
chant très bien je te l'avais dit à quel
dommage qu'elle soit si désordonnée
ce gentil des troncs venu françois parce
que hippolyte était très ennuyée ans
c'est très vrai il ne voulait pas dire
que les choses gentilles mais comme il
est très timide
il est un peu mal à nos parents c'est
vrai c'est très vrai
c'est de ma faute j'ai été maladroit je
n'aurais jamais dû me vexer tout à
l'heure j'ai été idiot ça c'est encore
plus vrai qu'on soit versée aux cantons
oh tu vois il est toujours comme ça eve
mais ne vous en faites pas avec julie je
vais faire très très attention à rien je
vais la chercher au whisky je suis quasi
tu veux bien revenir une minute
hippolyte a tellement aimé ta chanson il
voudra pour féliciter
les compliments salut hippolyte bonjour
mademoiselle
vous avez quelque chose à me dire
vas-y vas-y
quel dommage que que vous soyez si
désordonnée
merci les charmants ton cousin nîmois
attend laisse le terminer oh ben non
c'est suffisant comme ça qu'on dit m non
mais je me permets d'insister hippolyte
et si timide qu'il en est maladroit
pointe de leur moi même je me suis vexé
mais écoute le chant prix bon si vous
assistez je veux que vous me dire ce
cousin
quel dommage que vous soyez si
désordonnée sauf que sans ça vous avez
toutes les qualités du monde
c'est vraiment trop gentil politique est
pour vous pour me faire pardonner je
vais vous faire une surprise à bout oui
c'est merveilleux mais ne fait pas de
folies non non non non attendez moi la
bataille d'accord d'accord
je vous l'avais dit ça fait psg je me
suis trop vite vexé hippolyte est
tellement maladroit médecine il ne pense
qu'à rodez erasme
casque
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive hippolyte
qu'est ce qui te prix bas c'est ma
surprise
un grand nettoyage de ton casque en
désordre pas par la célèbre méthode du
vide 1 1 mais tout n'est pas contente
elle n'est pas content tu n'es pas
content quand j'étais si content moi